Now we can look at this as a decision problem
and we'll call it the long and simple path decision problem and it goes like this.
Given a graph G and a link L and two nodes U and V,
is there a simple path from U to V consisting of L or more nodes?
We're not looking for a short path, we're actually looking for a long and simple path,
and we're going to imagine and I'm saying imagine because I actually don't know
whether this is true or not, but we're going to imagine that there is an algorithm
that solves this decision problem, yes or no correctly,
and its running time is n to the k for some constant k like two.
Θ(n²) or 10 like Θ(n¹⁰) or a thousand Θ(n¹⁰⁰⁰) but k is not a function of n.
It can't be an exponential or it's going to be bounded by some polynomial.
It could be a nasty polynomial, but let's just imagine that it's bounded by a polynomial.
Here's a different problem. Find a simple path from U to V in G consisting of L or more nodes.
This one is just asking me yes no question. This one is actually asking for the path.
And we'd like to know is there a polynomial time solution to this problem, we'll call it problem B.
Assuming that there is a polynomial time solution for problem A.
We can use the solution of problem A as subroutine in solving problem B. All right.
Here's how we like you to do it.
I want you to write a Python command called long and simple path that takes a graph G
and node U, node V, and the link L
and it's allowed to call long and simple decision with whatever it wants.
As many time as it wants as long as it's a polynomial in the number of
nodes and edges in the graph, and ultimately return the path that there is one.
Here's a little skeleton to get you started.
We call long and simple decision G, U, V, L and if it's the case that the decision problems says
or the solution to this decision problem says there is no path of link L or greater from U, V, and G
then you don't have to do anything, just return false.
But otherwise, you actually need to build and return the path as a list of nodes
and the first element, at least should be U and the last element should be V
and all the steps in between should be actual edges
and the total number of nodes on that path needs to be at least L.